sony has a massive ps4 price drop which  goes into effect today through December  19 helping you pick up the console for  just 300 bucks that's 850 Dell Amash  down from its original price and is the  same discount that Sony offered during  Black Friday and Cyber Monday the price  applies to the Star Wars Battlefront  standard edition bundle and the  Uncharted the Nathan Drake collection  bundle the offer is available at a  number of retailers across the US but  you may still want to take your time  deciding which retailer to opt for since  the McCain to give you even more free  craps for your hard-earned dollars for  example Best Buy is offering up a free  copy of destiny the taken king legendary  edition when you buy the Uncharted  bundle and that's a pretty damn good  deal let me know down in the comments if  you're planning to pick up a console  this Christmas and stay tuned to game  spot for all the latest